frente a las puertas de la cumbre de las
américas de los ángeles estás drag
queens se dirigen a joe biden le
pidieron presionar a yale bolsonaro
acusado de no respetar el medio ambiente
y los derechos de los indígenas adentro
el presidente brasileño se defendió la
amazonía es una cuestión de soberanía
para su país
bolsonaro prefiere insistir en un
entendimiento entre brasilia y
washington
estamos muy interesados será un
acercamiento en estrechar aún más los
lazos con eeuu stage y hemos tenido
buenas relaciones desde hace casi 200
años en dubai donde adoptó el mismo tono
conciliador las relaciones tensas con
jair bolsonaro parecen olvidadas tal
como la preocupación de washington por
las próximas elecciones en brasil brasil
es un lugar maravilloso con un pueblo
maravilloso con una democracia vibrante
e inclusiva en instituciones electorales
fuertes nuestras naciones están unidas
por valores comunes muy arraigados que
en mi opinión abren oportunidades
increíbles para nuestras dos naciones el
presidente estadounidense ha sido
criticado por varios líderes
latinoamericanos tras la decisión de
excluir de la cumbre cuba-venezuela y
nicaragua países que eeuu no considera
suficientemente democráticos y el hecho
de ser país anfitrión de la cumbre no
otorga la capacidad de imponer el
derecho de admisión sobre los países
miembros del continente para washington
en la cumbre regional debía ser una
oportunidad para reparar sus lazos con
américa latina' después del mandato de
donald trump un objetivo que está lejos
de alcanzarse